That's the special thing about coffee, it's
such a very light
drug. You need a coffee, you
need a coffee to wake up,
so that's of course
a real need, no, so when you
're on the highway you  you have to go to the toilet
and you just need coffee to be able to
continue driving, so it's
a bit fashionable, especially in
city locations, but there are also a lot of
real needs that you
fulfill and otherwise there's
probably a bit of a
trend that coffee is being substituted among the younger
generation  is through
other
drinks that we also have to offer,
so these cold drinks also
coffee cold drinks but also energy drink
based cold drinks that we have to
offer
insofar it may be that
coffee in its classic function
is the same as it is today, that it is also undergoing a change,
hello  you are müheimer then I
was born in Mülheim and grew up
in mülim for the first 22 years and then
ulenhaus mülleheim hockey.
I
always saw Essen alsofar and then
you won 92 gold in squat exactly exactly exactly
but I was there for 3
years  in Munich to study and but
I actually learned the whole thing
at ulnosmüller okay and to
this day you are I h she in Munich ne
exactly exactly I stayed DAH your
your hockey career wasn't
that long either so you have, so to speak  At the
peak of 25, I somehow
worked with the team and then
realized that nothing more was possible and now
I'm giving advice in this case. Yes,
I have to admit that I was always in the
b squad and was then
at the peak of my performance for a year
and it was
somehow already foreseeable that I
would disappear from the b squad again and
then I decided after
this medal that this was actually the
right time to stop. Then I
stopped national economics
and then the Bundesliga and the following year
Then I
quickly got into a real
full-time job, so to speak. Berger is in Dannau,
then I started Roland Berger for 6 years when I was
25 and then
after the third year I was already thinking about what
I could do as a self-employed person.
I always wanted to become self-employed
and then I just came  Didn't come
up with the right idea for a relatively long time and then went
to honeymoon in the USA and
saw Starbucks and then said
that it would certainly work in Germany too and
then copied something
and adapted it to Germany. Okay, that's
actually the
level of innovation, but V  It's also
incredibly competitive, so I mean,
Starbucks somehow managed to assert itself there,
but gastro in the broadest
sense, let's talk about it a little bit, there
's already a lot of
competition right from the start. Yes, of
course, Starbucks has already
managed to assert itself incredibly well on a world level
but at the
German level there are
only number 2 behind us and
in Germany the German consumer
is a bit more special, that's
why the adaptation
we made back then was
also important, it was totally
relevant, especially something with the
savory  food range
that our American competitor did
n't really have to this day
and
um that made it important so it was
a bit flippant with that
um simply copied but that was
a significant
further development for the German
market which was also necessary  was okay
now we're talking about 230 exactly 230
locations um and and 20 still abroad
and then we also acquired a sister
or a partner company campus suite
here in the far north
and we work closely together
basically on a platform of a
logistics platform  together with campused
so that was then
having another 30 more locations how did it start for you
so really just open a branch without any investment
and then somehow
step by step from cash to the next one
or was it clear right from the start you
get a big investor  in and
make 10 falen in the first year no,
we have that today you would say
Boots Bustards, we really did it at the
beginning with the savings from
the Rolandberg era, I went to the
bank and said I would like to
open a coffee shop and then did
The Deutsche Bank, where I had
previously done a banking apprenticeship,
first turned me away and the
Sparkasse then said yes, we can
do it, but only if you
stay with Roland Berger for another three years and
use your salary as security
That's how it was and my dear
wife actually had to manage the first store
operationally because I
had to work at Berger Blei 2 for another three years
and
so it ended up being completely
bank-financed with the highest, yes, yes,
so that's how it was when we opened the first store  If
I had set myself in the sand, I would have had
to stay at Rolandberger longer to pay it back and where was
the first store at Leopoldstrasse 70
in Munich and it
worked well straight away, the first store
worked very well but the second one did
n't work at all  was in
Düsseldorf, you have to close it six months
later, then in the
third we said we'll try it
again and otherwise we'll leave the whole
topic behind. The third was then in the valley in
Munich again, so Munich again
and it worked well again
and then we made the decision
that I would
move away from consulting from rolandberger and that was
now multiply and what is the
difference between that or what
makes a well-running W badlf
so how can the one in Munich do so well
and so on  bad or what so in
Düsseldorf as always it's very
location-heavy it's almost all
location in Düsseldorf we
made the incredible mistake of
going into a basement on the
Düsseldorfer köh that sounds great as a name
as there was a
basement and had  um in
a shopping center like that and it didn't have a
terrace outside, which means in the summer there are
always no guests for six months
because everyone wants to sit outside, that
was just the main mistake, there
were a few other mistakes,
including renting far too expensively and um
There are a few location criteria in the
German coffee shop business, you need
a corner location, you need a
south-west terrace and
ideally you also need tourists, i.e. hotels
nearby, and then you can
earn money in the city locations and in the
travel business, i.e. airports, train stations,
highways, it's much easier there
and that  These experiences that
you are now summarizing soberly
have been for at least 10 years
and today we
are still partly wrong, so now they are all
profitable. No, out of 230 locations
we always have an average of 5 until they
are loss-making and we then
have to close them down  We just have
rental terms that have to be carried
along for at least 20 years, so everyone is
an experiment, every new location is
an experiment. We have gotten better,
but it still
has a certain experimental function, especially in city locations,
and I will  still crazy when
you open a location on the third
day you don't see anything,
unfortunately you see that very early in our
store and you always think you have
n't learned anything in the last 20 years,
okay and tell me why doesn't he do a
pop-up like that  or something like that first or
you have to get into a long-term
rental agreement straight away otherwise you have
no
chance. Unfortunately you have to because you
also want the long-term
rental agreements and you want the good
locations and um you can't get it with
the pop-up you can't  go in and
say landlord I'm going to your
prime location on Düsseldorf Königsallee
but I would like to
go out again in half a year and I wo
n't invest but just
put in a coffee bike um you have to
try to negotiate the exit option
after 2 D years that is
Realistic but otherwise you have to
jump once in a while, crazy and how
much does it cost to open a
store like this, so we used to
have an average of €250,000 for years and today, due to
inflation, construction prices and so on, we're
probably closer to 350 to
350  okay and then the rental agreement is
with exoption z at least yes the
rental agreement is in the city locations and
you have to distinguish that from the traffic in
the city locations we always try
to get a total of 20 years over option
and we have to at least usually five
sometimes 10 years wow yes  That's a
really long time, so
you actually always have to sign for 5 years and what do
you have in a normal city location so
Munich Berlin Hamburg is probably
particularly expensive Düsseldorf maybe
but you're talking about if you
have to sign for 10 years or say five
what the
total contract volume is  That
's really bad
if you add it all up,
you can say for a very good
location in the top seven cities in
Germany you'll probably pay an
average of €10,000 so if you extrapolate that to €120
per year and have it  a 10
year contract you're always
in seven figures and um then
you still have construction costs
and then you still have the
operational risk that you
can also make losses along the way so it sounds like
we've been talking
about a lot of risks for quite a long time now
Business but that actually exists,
but there is always the possibility,
especially in good locations, of
re-letting to others who would
like to have the location
and there are a lot of possibilities
to minimize risks, but that
's just the
initial risks, okay, I  I'm
also Irish at the same time, such a moat is fashionable,
one would say, in the tech world for
others
Bahn, for example, and they do
n't really like taking
economically weak startups either, and
with that you have already
created a barrier to market entry if you
have a certain size, a certain
creditworthiness,
that you first of all, as you say,
a ring around your
castle  you built and what kind of sales
can you create with a store like this that is
now in a good location, so in the good
city locations it should actually be somewhere
between 600,000 a million
not that much that's not that
much that's a lot less than e.g
Lososteria Hans is lucky for full catering, they are
somewhere more than
2 million 2.5 million on average
also in McDonald's, for example, but we
just have small bongs, we have coffee and
we are very high-margin, we have a very
high margin but we also have a lot of
small bongs  Well, it's quite a
tedious business
to get to a million with small bongs
and but in the end you sell them as a
top product. Then I just sell the
Latte Machiato or what is it? The
strongest product for us is the
medium cappuccino, that's what it used to be  the
middle latte macchiato the trend
is a bit towards less milk
in total in lat maiato there is simply more
milk in it, of course it is
sometimes swapped for milk substitute and
lactose-free or plant-based
but there are also more and more espresso
drinkers and americano drinkers
have no milk in it at all and if there
is currently a cappuccino with little
milk in it, it is the strongest
product and what percentage
is coffee v
about 50%.  and the rest is then the
rest is based on there is
not yet coffee so tea there are
quite a lot of
summer specials so blended drinks in the summer there
is water and of course there is the
food area which makes around
25 to 30 for us  % and it is divided into
half sweet muffins and so on and
half heart bagels and that was
our big USP our big
difference to the American K
against Star that have no less
less and especially in the
early years less almost completely cooked  They didn't
follow suit at first, but we had that
okay from the start and that also
differentiated exactly that's why
people come in exactly but then it's
relatively low sales if you
think about it absolutely but still the
decisive factor yes it was the
differentiation sometimes  We
also got rental contracts with it because
people said, the landlords said
yes, we have offices upstairs, we need
an option at lunchtime, so that
was also a little more than now, but
it was more important for the consumer and above all it was the
big one  Differentiation simply from the
main competitor that we had a
hearty American but
hearty product in various
freshly prepared options, there was
still in this entire segment so
I mean there was even more
competition than just Starbucks, I
had balsack Koffe in Hamburg,
I once followed it  There was then,
like, somehow, um, Campus Suite that you
took over, but I do
n't really have a close look at the market, but how much
is there? So historically, they all
opened in 1999, they all came up with
the idea in the same year, which we
also came up with, all at the same time  There was nothing that
we all couldn't communicate with each other.
Some of them were lawyers in
Munich and in San Francisco. There were
other consultants
the
forerunner belongs to balsack and so on
World Coffee belongs to it and they
were then simply consolidated over the
years were bought up, merged
partially insolvent
and yes today there are
actually only three that
is Starbuck we and Espresso Haus you
bought balsack ah okay you  you
met Howard Schulz, the founder of Starbucks, no, unfortunately
not, he became one of the
richest Americans or
crazy absolutely absolutely absolutely unfortunately
never read his book with interest,
great respect for him, even
today, for his from our
main competitor  Starbucks has a lot of
respect, especially in the USA, a lot of
things are doing incredibly well,
but I didn't get to know him
and like, so to speak, I looked at the last
market capitalization,
I have to take a look  I estimate
that they are over 100 billion dollars.
I'll do the test right here,
quickly set the stock exchange app
to 108 10.8 crazy 10.8 yes
actually close then yes yes yes no we
are always around 100 and what, so
to speak,
gets you out of it  prevented from growing even further,
say already huge, but
if you think about it now that it's a completely
different world,
it's probably just D the
home market is so strong or or
what difference
so that's right that's the
point is totally valid we're in one
Now in a global comparison, we are more of a
market leader in a market that is not quite as
attractive as the USA, for example.
That is certainly the attractiveness
of our own market, which is certainly one
reason why we
have not grown quickly. It may
also be a bit too much German,
um, reticence, so we wanted to  Never
grew aggressively too quickly through private equity and maybe even a stock market listing because I
always wanted to stay in the
majority with the shares and
the voting rights. It was always important to me
that I never
have to chair a general meeting at some point, I
think it's a mix like that  I when when
did the first investor come in with you
um
2000 no in
2008 2008 the first investor came in
was 22 with a capitalization of 22% of the
shares
my wife and I had the rest at 78 then at
some point we were
able to buy the shares back
through an et  Deal we
sold our train stations in franchise to Fr
bahnh bahnhal exactly got fresh money
and with the money we were able to
buy out the investor again
then kept the shares in the GmbH for 3 years and
gave them to the current partner BWK
which is a subsidiary of the Landesbank
We have had Baden-Württemberg since 2014 with this 22%
on board, this S 10 years in it, which
is also quite long, so we chose a very good
long-term partner,
among other things,
because they were not Anglo-Saxon, let's
say in 5 years
we'll be out again  and we said we
would like to be in it for 10 or 20 years
and would be happy if we could be partners in the long term
and you
now also have franchises, you are unlucky so you have to
talk about what
kind of concepts you offer, but is
that the plan for you at some point
Let's get investors on board or do you
say no, I'm growing nicely now for
the next few years, so at
some point in 10 years I'll have
400 branches in Europe, that's enough for me,
so such a growth
perspective isn't
quite perfect per se  wrong very bad
m
So maybe just a quick word about the
franchise we we that was certainly
one of the reasons that
is important for the German market that we believed in
franchises or in leaseholders from the start.
Peasters are the ones
where we invest ourselves and keep all the risks
but the  Hand over the keys of the fully
furnished store to an operator
who pays a kind of sales rent
and the Fr nemer is one who
invests everything himself hard. I GLB gives
a manual, I looked at it,
you have to pay 50,000 once. You will be
unlucky there or sizes once
I've
noticed that if you pay 300,000, then you become a
franchisee, that's
exactly how it is and we've had
great experience with our partners
in the stores because, as you've already
correctly stated, we have
relatively small sales per store  and
sometimes we have a store in Baden
Baden and there is
nothing around it for quite a long time, which means the
control effort for the individual store
is relatively high until someone
drives there and so on, then
it just makes sense that there
is a franchiser in there, which by the way  Yes,
also in many of the entire
system catering in Germany,
the majority of the
successful concepts are French
systems also have something
to do with the German labor law and, um, from the
growth perspective,
we are now the
market leader in Germany and we will get help if there is
an insolvency somewhere or
a successor  There are or
location packages somewhere then we
actually always get it on the table and have
actually been able to
grow quite well with it over the years
and so it's a
good perspective as of now, but now we're
really tackling Europe, so to speak, abroad or
something like that, that doesn't make any sense, so we
are  Yes, we already have about 25 stores abroad,
you could say that it's a
bit of
testing. We would
now no longer be as afraid
or have as much respect before taking a bigger step abroad as we did
maybe 5 years ago and
of course there are abroad  Exactly such
options also mean that the coffee shop player is
coming onto the market number 2 number 3
from the country and I see
considerable potential there, I mean if you
now look at the total sales you know
my standard question that the company is
trying to feed is not at all  it's
so complicated you can
approach it somehow and say okay 260 branches on average
make almost a month of sales then you
should be yes we are not
we are not because we have a
special feature we have um the tank and
race
locations in the tank and
race rest stops by the way  very
positive partnership with the tank and races
and races on the German motorway exactly
one motorway and there
we usually only have about 5 se m that
are in a rest stop like that and
then sometimes there is the kiosk or
a McDonald's or something like that  On
average, we don't make the million or
half a million that we need in the cities
if we build a really
big store, so we're
on average at 400,450 because we
have a lot of these rest stops, so
mathematically we
currently have an average turnover
of  say 450,000 and multiply that
by the openings and so we're
somewhere around 115,120 million this year, okay, but it
's still, I mean, and that's
still in the business that's on board
with the money that flowed in, then there
's little  Just a little money in
today's terms for so much sales,
no, exactly, if you think about the fact
that you have to collect it with 6 € bongs, that
's
a lot for us. We sometimes think like
a few years ago, we somehow have
that  I collected the money that evening and counted it myself.
My wife and I then had it in the cash register and
we are already proud that this
120 million has now come out of it
and the next growth would also come
from the cash you have  Then
you're now so
profitable that you can say okay, there's a
market coming up in France now, then
you can then build up exactly the
smaller packages you could make from the
cash flow, but in terms of the overall leverage,
a sensible part would probably be
taken from bank financing  and then take the rest through
equity capital from the cash
okay okay but I've also
made acquisitions in Germany
that sometimes didn't work out
absolutely absolutely we weren't always
we didn't always have a lucky
hand especially the first
the first  There were about 20
shopping center
coffee shops that were in East German
shopping centers, they were all
serviced so there was service and we then
smoked a year before then smoking was not allowed
and then we said from
now on please do self-service
It wasn't great at all and then
sales fell by 30% and then
we installed our shop
and threw out the existing shop fittings, which
had
double leasing rates, so it was
quite a disaster and we have
made two more acquisitions since then
and I think we have continued to
improve, but we still have
significant learnings with every purchase,
okay, but I think that
all this can cause me and and
you can laugh about it today, me, these
are also things that can cause a few
sleepless nights  were there I would like to say
that it's already risky for the entire company
if it
goes to [ __ ] then it's totally totally so we have,
um, always also under in the
covid period, um, I did
n't sleep well for a few nights, um, that's it
Most entrepreneurs will
know you in some form or another, but if you've been
in business for 25 years, we've been in
business for 24 years, um, we've
had real worries a few times, yes,
but never in any way. I
mean, you've been spoken to every now and then
You don't
even want to sell or you don't even want to
somehow now then now today
really take in a PR equity or
something like that but that doesn't seem
to motivate you either, yes, I mean, I'm
55 now,
I don't want to go to
my wife right away  Sit on the sofa and
carry the rubbish out there or
something like that, but I would definitely like to continue to push my business for a
few more years
and
this European perspective is
interesting, there are also
a few
ideas in the German market that we still have  The
hotel idea might come later, a
few years later, I think,
and then, to be honest,
at some point in time you'll definitely have to
take a look. We also have children to see whether they'd
like to go there in their original form
or whether they'd like to have a partner with them
in which you do
n't have to sell everything, but
you can also stay in it with shares
and and have a private equity
that will also buy out the existing one,
perhaps at some
point in time. I think that has to be
evaluated and and that's where we have it  It's still a
few years away, but of course these are
issues that we'll
have to face at some point, just because of
my age, what's weighing on you the most, what's weighing
on you the most? The business model is
getting staff, it's rising rents, so to speak,
probably not at the moment
So to speak, the change in
inner cities, so to speak, so first of all it's
a very robust model viewed from the outside, very
very diversified
as a very small B, so to speak, the exact W
I say very granularly, the one big
customer disappears, that can't be it,
but there are still probably
risks and  I have now
said suffering perspective somehow
personnel is an issue then change
inner cities is an issue what else so
we always differentiate what are
structural problems that remain and
that primarily
affect us the issue with the personnel
we all have the same and that will
probably happen with it  solved that was that that
was that salaries have to continue to increase
and everyone else has to do that too
and then at some point the capuccino will
cost €5 on average in Germany
for everyone so that's
no reason for me to
say that I'm panicking  I'm
also not panicking about inflation,
which is already
causing us considerable concern this year because we have
the phenomenon this year that we
have fewer visitors
even though we have significantly higher
average receipts, but we have
10% more sales than 3 years ago, but
we need  20% more sales to
absorb the entire increase in costs,
but we believe that this is a temporary
phenomenon and that we will have sweated out the economic situation at some
point in 2 D years.
The city business in the
cities is and will remain difficult in Germany, among other things, this
crazy competition with the  Bakers and
the travel business is still doing relatively well
in these three
travel locations, highway station,
airport and there is and that is
now the big issue that worries us a
bit because we do
n't have infinite growth potential in
cities. You would have infinite
growth potential  The
traffic locations are spread out somewhere,
my airport will be free, it will be
advertised and then you have a
chance, but there are no longer
50 airports that
can somehow fit shops in, so that's a
bit of an idea that can be
solved through growth abroad mhm and but
inner cities  Are you now saying that bakers are causing
problems because Germany has
a lot of good bakers exactly and and they
go in with your segment and
also sell a coffee with have
actually always been there and
we actually came in, yes or so exactly
and were there for a while  in the coffee at the front
but we also have them quite well on
good bakers we have also
caught up well so when I
look at young people here in Hamburg good bakers
with good
coffee and that's
structurally the big
difference to England and America there is
none not in the quality and
generally the way things are going in the cities. The upheaval in
inner cities is also a
problem. How do you take the W or is it
all a lot of talk? No, that's true.
Home office also causes problems for us in the
locations where we have a lot of
office people  That's already an
issue and you can actually only
solve it through lower rents because
the rents are often due to the death
of textiles, the rents
in the retail sector are also on the decline and
you then have to demand that from the
landlord,
um that's it  then a bit of the
corrective no so okay but that means
generally you say there is still enough there
to do any business at all if the
rent is okay then it is
not dead now so not Hamburg and Munich
anyway but we are now also talking
about smaller ones  Cities no, the
smaller cities are not easy in
Germany,
Hamburg, Munich and Berlin, especially
Berlin, are easier for our
business model because we
have a lot of tourists there, tourists are
very important
hotels, large hotels are important
in Campton and Memmingen City is not
that easy  Biberach even less but
it's okay we'll do it okay
we'll do it but if we make the plan
for the next 10 years today and
the capital allocation then I think we'll come
to Biberach a little less
than maybe 20
years ago okay and now you say one  The way
could also be to open our own hotels.
We already have
eight hotels of our own. We
came up with it a little bit because the
hoteliers always asked us. Do
n't you want to do the ground floor
and the breakfast room with us and then
we always have GT, yes we can  We're already
doing it, but it's only worth it if we're
allowed to take part in the bed business
and if we lease the whole thing. They
said no, no,
we'll do the beds ourselves and then at
some point we thought, now let
's try the bed business, it
somehow seems more attractive  to be
the gastronomy and then we
did a test in Dortmund and it
actually went really well because we have
coffeellos downstairs on the ground floor and
upstairs we have
rooms furnished according to the coffeellos model and
people come for breakfast and
check-in  And so they come to
Coffeefellows and have a small
reception desk and then we
opened the first location there and
I was pleasantly surprised. Then
a few more locations were
added and we want to continue to
grow with that, but that's really so
classic  you attach a booking
to it, do you have 200 beds
or how many are there then you have to
have so we are just in the process of building
our
we have hotels with 60 rooms that
are always usually
120 beds um  60 rooms and we
also have 160 and 170 rooms are the
bigger ones anyway and I think we're
trying to get 100 rooms and
that's often our model, so
Mr. Müller, who was with you,
we can't get offended by him either
If
a huge piece of land somehow becomes available at the Munich train station, the
first thing to do is to
write to the miller and then get married
and then at some point number 23
will come, then our model is rather
the more difficult cases that we
take over older hotels that are actually
in good locations  and who
have a need for renovation and where nobody really wants
to renovate because the owner
often wants to sell or wants to get out and
then
we buy with us or
we try to buy the objects on the
real estate site
and then renovate it to a
coffeefellow like that  Z D years and
then really run it
for the long term and um have both in
hand okay that means you do
n't do everything from the beginning Big Bang
new, but gradually you change
it around in Coffeeelwu's hotel exactly exactly exactly
and there you have it  For example,
three of us have now been completely
remodeled, but we are still
renovating five more, or two
three are still waiting, are still
completely old, actually they are
n't called Coffee Fellows either, we always add
Coffe Fellows Hotel only when everything
is finished and  That's you, the
owner of the real estate partly
yes, out of eight locations
we have four or five where we as the
really big ones, the two big ones in Munich are
n't, they would also be too expensive,
we can't afford that, but the
middle ones are trying  we then to
acquire okay not with coffeefellows
but with
a private circle of investors so
friends and family ah okay okay we I'm
just about to say you would have to
free up a lot of capital yes
yes that's what we've been trying to separate
SMer arms for a long time as that so beautifully means
no party is
allowed to suffer damage in any way, it has to be somehow too
market conditions but
we do that with friends
investors or with family or something like that
buy it and
on the other hand we always rent it
with coffeefellows and coffee
fellellows is also so strong
that there are people  or is everything
good on booking, even with booking
you need a
brand, ideally
coffeellos tells you of course that you
get good coffee and that you
get a good breakfast,
people also assume that and after that
they go in relatively heavily  the rating
and then look at the rating
about location and about service and so
on
and that's actually what the decision is made on and that's what we have
that we weren't sure what
coffe Fellows says in the hotel market but
we call it coffe Fellows Hotel  the
brand um and we are
amazed at how easy it is for the
overnight guests to
understand this.
In the end you are building a
hotel brand on a coffee on
a coffee brand
and it actually sounds
almost logical somewhere that it
could work somehow  If you go through a Starbucks
Hotel it would also work. There are
probably Armani Hotels too, there are some that are
still
close, but of course there are high quality clothes and
stuff, but with you
somehow breakfast and
coffee are part of the hotel for many people
So to speak, pulling back the
value chain or whatever
the perception
is actually quite
clever, but people still come
via booking at the end or do
they also come a lot directly via we don't have a
booking share of around 50% at all
so much and then the other
channels again like 15 xedio and HS and
so on and then we have an average of 30
35% of our own channels so whether that's
email or our website
so our own booking tools
and that's it  In terms of price,
the hotel is
sort of settled so if the finished coffee
then finished Motel One ah okay so
already 100 € on average so sometimes a
little more sometimes a little less
Dortmund is cheaper than Munich
but around 100 100 € 90 110  120 how
much of the franchisee or pechter who runs your branches
how much do
you make yourself in the coffee business yes
so of those let's say 230
are five to eight of our own that we
really run ourselves ah okay
not much at all and then of the rest
about two thirds are franchisees and that
and a third is lease okay there is
a really strong
franchise business I wouldn't have that at all
okay it's really very
franchise oriented it also depends a
bit on the fact that the tank and races
we have over 130 locations,
the category is all towards hard
Franchise because we don't own any ETS
ah and with the hotels it
's all self-operated, it
may be that we'll change that at some point,
but we don't have this
control problem because the
sales we
can make are getting bigger and bigger  you check a lot, you also
drive there and so on and
we want to do this in our own business for the time being and
you already have the first
franchise millionaires who
have become rich with you with branches of some kind
and so on, so you have to
say that with us you have to  You do
n't invest as much as with
McDonald's, but we have as many franchise
millionaires as McDonald's, but
we haven't
produced them either, so I think that's
a bit of a different type. Often
the tenants in particular are often
former shop managers somewhere
at M CAF e.g. 25 28 not
so
capital strong and the
franchisers earn
good money on average but not according to McDonald's
standards okay but be there when
someone says, man, I'm
here somewhere now and have now managed a M
cffe or I don't know  a
coffee extra sheet or something and you
want to do something of your own then they call
you, they are precise and we are
also more than open to taking other good,
interested partners on board.
We have a high level of mutual
loyalty, so the partners stay with us for a long time
and enjoy being with us  and vice versa,
our side doesn't want these changes
either and anyone who is interested is
warmly invited and how many can
you operate with you? I learned from
Torsten tüller on the podcast that
franchises were eaten up and so he did
n't like it at all  Many of them
have hundreds of branches because then
they probably have too much
house.
In your case,
someone has three branches or
sometimes 2030 2030 not but 34
is quite typical and especially
regional so it's important to us  In the
interest of the franchise namer that
his distances between branches
are not that far, we have unfortunately
already had painful experiences
when we have asked him to do too much
or have not protected him,
but three four are nearby in
one city  or something like that makes perfect
sense, okay, and
in the end you still have millions in business, you own
parts of it, absolutely, so these
are real entrepreneurs who also
really push forward in terms of volume
to GmbH
with, so they sometimes also have their own
offices and their own  Admin people, that's it, there are
also people who have eight
eight locations Z locations but
at some point it stops being
relevant to you, so I mean, it
sells coffee now, so it's
not incredibly complex, I imagine that, but
somehow, yes
you have to get the coffee from somewhere
or like
with coffee, it's
not
important that you get it somehow,
but it's important that A
is good coffee and B but also and it
's not just us who want that
but it is also really demanded
by the customers that it is sustainably
grown with social standards,
no child labor,
that it is certified and
that we also know where it comes from and we
have
built up four growing regions over the
years, we know the cooperative ones there
or some of them too  The farmers
and we certify the companies and have them
certified according to a
minimum standard
so that we can simply say that it is good coffee but
also with a clear conscience that
it is really properly
produced and
grown and and that is important in
our business so it applies  for everyone
no, but that is particularly
important and I think we have been a
leader for all these years,
that has been more and more in
the value chain, we
have Tanzania is a cultivation Colombia
Brazil and India D is you  Since I was on
the road myself, here are the pictures
exactly. We were also on site in
Tanzania two years ago, we
also picked there and
looked at it. So it's really a level of
value creation that also
determines success - that you can
get it cheaply  that it is good
quality so that is already
differentiating that it is cheap due to the
high prices that the coffee has, it
is clear that it should not
be extremely overpriced but it is the
success factor that is less that it
is now incredibly cheap it has to be good
reasonable ratio in terms of
price it has to be good above all good
and it has to
be comprehensibly sustainable that's
more important than cheap but somehow it's
not as much of a
differentiating feature as a
location is now so you can't just because of a good
coffee or cheap coffee
Compensate for the situation or what
that doesn't work no, so the
success factor is
more and more, at first glance it is
easier
to source exactly such a coffee and but
then it also requires many years of marketing
and supply chain knowledge and
market knowledge and and
Growing region you may be right, I
know where you're coming from with your statement,
but
we see coffee as the real USP of
our system with this sustainable
[music]
traceability in the
value chain, we see that
in my core industry, I hear the media say
that it's always like that  People say here
somehow that doesn't exist, the
Spiegel doesn't know costs 4 € and
a coffee now costs more and
the daily newspaper costs 3 € and
even the coffee is more expensive and
somehow there is always the issue
with a paywall  People are not willing to
pay money for a subscription and
every coffee is always said to
cost
4, 5, 6 € or even more these days, how can
that actually be and I have to say
I sometimes wonder because I'm
crazy about it  Do people spend 6 7 € on coffee
and somehow not on a newspaper
or on something where it is now clear that a
lot of people have worked in the background,
now turned around, the question sometimes makes you
worry that it
may not be sustainable that
the coffee is like that  is expensive now
compared to, for example, some
other
products, yes the coffee is well
calculated but what you shouldn't forget of course is that
we are in the
fixed cost business where we have expensive rents,
expensive leasing rates, expensive staff
and only when you go over it on the
day when you go over it  If you go above these
fixed costs then it's fun and
your h first a problem due to high
fixed costs and there are always
shops where it just doesn't
work that way. I would put it another way.
The bagel costs €6 for us and it has
more  Consumption of goods in absolute numbers
than the pizza which costs an average of 15 outside
and
these coffee shops are
in any case not
favored at all in the food sector but there is the
pizzeria is favored and in the
coffee then we simply have to
earn the money for our our  To
pay rent and our leasing installments and in the
end we come up with it from the customer,
I don't care, he somehow says
€6, I don't care what the costs
are, it's too expensive for me for the coffee at the
moment, so this would have
always been my fear and  I would also have
thought, well, of course you can sell a newspaper
or a magazine more expensively than
a coffee, but that doesn't seem to be the case, so
I was wrong, but
now I'm wondering if anyone
has actually won this bet  which is permanently won or do
you sometimes worry that
the world can change and at some point
coffee may be as a
fashion accessory that it is also somewhere else,
so the German is extremely
price-conscious and we must not overdo it at all
every 10  Cents that we
go up, we notice with fewer purchases
that that that that that
always returns to normal after a few months, but
especially before the big inflation
two years ago, we had
to think for so long about every 10 cents whether we would
go up from 92 to 3  EUR now is
somehow all the prices are now
a bit out of control
but that will happen again because
the Germans are looking very closely at it,
I know in Switzerland
I have seen prices at a large
competitor of an average of 10  € 10
francs 10 francs even more than euros
so you can always see where the
trip is going at some point in Germany, too, at the
airport,
admittedly, but
we, you, you're right about both, we
have to be extremely careful because the
customer is just like you are now  He
really pays attention to what
price we charge for a coffee, um on
the other hand, the coffee is the same for everyone.
You can
no longer offer the coffee for 3, 20 in a few years,
that will
have to continue to rise due to inflation  and
still this argument that
coffee is a bit of
a fashion accessory, I
always said it in a mean way or something exaggerated,
but I don't know a film, so
nowadays you come to an appointment with
a coffee in your hand  Well, it was
n't like that before, there's no
guarantee that it will stay that way,
or you say, well, it's
now established like that, they're somehow
manners or habits that
were created there, they don't go
away anymore, so the coffee  Of course,
fortunately, that's what's special about coffee, it's
such a very
light drug
On the
highway you have to go to the toilet and
you just need coffee to be able to
continue driving, so it's
a bit of a fashion, especially in the
city locations, but there are also a lot of
real needs that you fulfill and
otherwise there's probably a
bit of a trend that that too  For
the younger generation, coffee
is substituted by other
drinks that we also have to offer,
so these cold drinks also include old
coffee drinks but also
energy drink-based cold drinks that
we have to offer,
so it may be that
coffee in its classic function is the same
as it is today  which is also undergoing a wall of
change,
we are also very careful in
the USA there is a competitor of our very
big competitor who is having huge
success with their own energy drink-based
drinks, so they do
n't have Red Bull or something like that, but they
have an energy drink mixture from
which they then  They make five six different
energy drinks based on cold drinks and
they already make more sales
than a big competitor with coffees
and you look at that
and ask yourself when is it since?
I look at that and ask myself whether it's going
to Germany or not  I would like to say whether it's an
opportunity for us too, it would be
an opportunity for you, but that's
not expected at the moment.
We're going to test it now.
The nice thing about our business is that
you can always test the product in three stores
and see how they do it
German consumers are reacting to this,
it is by no means the case that
everything that
works in the USA will also work in Germany,
but it may be
that this is an issue that we
have to stay on top of, what about retail,
i.e. the brand  Speaking of which, the brand
is suitable for building hotels now,
obviously you could also sell coffee
or coffee products or something similar to
retailers,
absolutely absolutely
right, I had
imagined it would be a bit easier, we
've already made a few attempts,
but it wasn't that
easy  I have to admit, although our
brand does have brand recognition,
we are competing with other
brands that have occupied the places in the food retail sector for many years
and we also found
the business style in the food retail sector to be
different to what we usually
know, um
and I basically give you that in the
medium term  I agree with you completely,
I think I would rather do it through
licensing with someone who
has an idea about this food retailer,
i.e. a consumer goods company who
has an idea, who drives their people who
can also do consumer goods marketing
and, um, um, sales people  They
know the buyers there and, um, it's
on the list as potential,
okay. Speaking of marketing, you
hardly do any marketing at all. I saw on Instagram that
there are 13,000 people who follow you,
yes, but I hardly see any other
advertising for you
Well, first of all, we're total fans of
in-house marketing that we say we
don't do much we we we have this
wastage because we were always afraid
that if we had a radio spot that
most of them would listen to that so they'd
always have one of those  A bit of
difficulty with five stores in one
city then doing radio advertising, for example
out of this fear and
always have the whole idea,
we always have what we do in the stores,
we try to
market it well and
are already taking the first
steps  I'm also on social media
with the number of
followers, which can still be expanded,
but we're already doing
a lot and we also have a good
team for it,
but I think historically it's always been
important for us to keep the store itself good  to
advertise and present what we do in the stores
well. I mean, you have
a whole lot of touchpoints.
If you think about how many, you have a key word
small bong, so high frequency, you have an
incredible number of touchpoints with
people, so
you know other ideas  I do
n't know what you could do with it, I do
n't know. In-store media business
that you recently
met someone who told me that he
now has displays hanging in McDonald's branches or in
various I think it was also
Rossmann branches
Since now somehow only
the advertising on it sells no, that
means parts from Rossmann or with
McDonald's and and some
gas stations and
just some displays, things like that must
also be an issue for you,
yes, that's where we've
always had ideas
We have some ideas. I don't want that
as an
excuse for not
doing more, no, you're definitely right. If you're
successful, you don't have to
justify yourself. No no no, but
you're definitely right  certain ideas
but we also had some ideas
that would have contributed to it or
they and they have that were
n't so easy with the franchise
partners because the frch partners are
basically bosses in their store whether they
originally belonged to us and from  was invested in us
but that's what we want,
we want them to say that
the chair is now there and there is
n't a display of
xy and that's why we have
a certain amount of restraint when it comes to some topics,
including what we push into the stores
of new commercial
ideas
and let's say it's important that the
brand is well represented by
our franchise partners,
we also invest a lot of
capacity and
we do a lot of visits and a Mel Shopper and D, but
we tend to hold back a bit
with everything that is a bit
so distracting on brand perception in
the stores, that means you're
essentially now controlling acquisitions expansion
and no a little bit the brand keyword
hotels maybe er food so
the stores themselves you do
n't have that at all  close to you because
the franchisees do that, but you
develop the brand and and for the
company exactly so yes, we actually
had a long-standing dichotomy, um
I have management colleagues,
Sven Ernst, who always looked after the
existing business, he was like that  You
would say COO and I
was the business development man and
finance, I always took care of the new
business, the new rentals, the
transactions for hotels and these
things and then there was Sven
who did the existing business that
we have now  A little bit because we
saw a certain need due to the size, Sven took over the
entire hotel business alone and we
broke down his original area a bit into three
four headoff positions
in order to simply have a strong supply chain,
strong IT and
digitalization area and so on  further
what what what is with you so
digitalization so that's what you hear
everywhere as a word what does it mean exactly so
with us again in-store a
lot of in-store thought
we want to be similar to what McDonald's
does that will eventually arrive in the
coffee shops that you  You
no longer need the cashier function and no longer
need it to the extent to free up the cashier
for other activities,
so you have these kiosks with which
you can order, we are
now piloting them. At some point you will have your app or
a QR code on the table with which you can
order  You can digitize the checkout process,
so it's a very big
project and it also has huge economic
implications because basically
30% of the personnel costs come from this
checkout function and we
probably won't need it anymore in 5 years
because we have the few
people we need at all
We still want to get them into the
production and into the
coffee production, for example, that
's a big topic, um then a
few smaller topics like we have an
e-commerce shop and um we have
an app now with the loyalty function
where  We replace our old stamp card
with a digital loyalty
function where we can have it scanned and so
at the checkout you
actually looked again at the keyword Starbucks
what Soz say because the malpitz
in your store so we just
said 100 billion marketcap what
make them for sales you know
that Starbucks will definitely do
the test I
check I said let me let me
then I would say a third
less sales than the stock market valuation 70
million okay so now what would be my best
guess million
sales so here  According to my ad Inter
research, only 32 billion in 202, so that
means they are
worth a factor of 3 on the stock market, which means for you
if you say 120 then it is
already the case then it would now also have
a few French
partners who are at airports, for example  always
franchised companies I don't know whether
the franchise fees are included or the external
sales for us are the external sales
of 120 million and that can be the
external sales the
brand sales net sales of the Starbucks
Corporation here then that is
the external sales made with the brand
will be a little higher is
higher than 32 million okay then
it will be a mixture of own businesses
and franchises Starbucks has a
lot of own businesses but
of course they also have franchises and that's
why this mix of 32 is
a mix that could well be that the
50  60 billion okay that means then
you say that the maltepill is
more like that not three but more like that
I don't know maybe 1 come
something probably yes I would
also have said the Malti is 1.5
on the system turnover so that's what we mean
carry to your world then the
company would now be worth 200
million
if someone were to say
human somehow Stefan now is now is
time now is time 200 million
will take that so a wouldn't
take
and whether it would hypothetically be worth it
I don't know
because I do
n't think we have identical multiples because
Star of course already has higher multiples
due to its size and the
stock market listing and this global number
1, so I think we would have to go
down to EBITA multiples 2 to 3, so if
Starbucks has 20 we might have 15
or 17
and we have a different mix
between our own sales and
the system sales so Starbucks has let
's say 70 system sales and or
or 50 system sales and 32 real sales
we have 120 system sales
but 35 or 40
own sales from the franchise fees and
so on  We
are I don't know if I do
n't want to come up with your number now, so it's
totally logically implausible, it's
probably not, but as a
good German bourgeois entrepreneur I would
stack it a little lower, yes, well,
I mean, the more you would have to
take it, so if  If someone B then
you would say, come on, we don't own
almost 80% or not quite somehow
you can
deal with that, at least from my point of view that would be
the upper one
with a real distance upper one
in the in the in the in the in the evaluation range
we have some say  systemgastronomien
also had some real problems in the last few years, there
was a piano or something like that,
I read it, yes, totally, well,
lososter, I think it was sold quite well, the
piano
went bankrupt, there were a few transactions,
I know DIN david was also half sold  the
multiples now not
but the nice thing is in the system also
in the German
system catering there are great
founder stories
also completely independent of us and there
is also a mark in the head so who
is so where tell me man that I
find saus litos Enchilada
Hans in  Lucky also Peter Panne and
Hamburg all from Blockhaus Blockhaus
is of course not the
founder story but is of course
also a long-established
system restaurateur, yes Mr. Block, so there
are already many who
have created it in Germany but a lot of them in
some form
Somehow it ended up in Anglo-Saxon hands.
At some point they had
enough and then they sold it. Yes, there
are few
German concepts or none at all that
I can think of that
have really become a global brand, but there are a
lot of Americans  in
Germany are very W that so we so
the home markets maybe we have
already talked about it or or or
GI yes the huge American
home market helps but also
this self-image of an
American to
open up Germany and to buy there with a lot of
capital power or
Dominos has bought all the pizza chains,
there are so many examples
where Germans are perhaps a bit too
timid and say no, I do
n't dare go to America now, I do
n't dare go to France or have
a brand themselves, but to say yes, good at the first
opportunity  then the
American comes along and then I just sell
or or there are just no products that
Germany now stands for so they
say irwi where coffee is not an
American h actually
has to be an Italian chain or
something like that maybe the espresso is
big worldwide  But yes, but
we have the other German system caterers, so we have
n't decided yet and yes, I think that's
more of a longer-term perspective,
but the many German colleagues who
have built up a great business
somehow all of a sudden at some point
was the company  is
now selling some Anglo-Saxon fund
with Henry McGovern with great
success or
with a competitor in the USA what
else is there for German, let's say
concepts that would have had the power W
say man, they could have made it even bigger
in the USA  Are there
really legends like American
billionaires who grew up with franchise food concepts
like the food kings,
some of whom I don't even say, I
recently read about it at his
congress about who was there and I
thought it was crazy,
I even knew the chains  Not but are there
concepts in Germany where
you said, man,
the North Sea could have been made even bigger
or or what would it have been great back then
so now probably not anymore
not anymore no but
hope hope the colleagues aren't there
but no but now  like the current
Germans like a Hans im Glück
or um Peter Panne or um lososteria
was piano I think they also
tried
internationalization then it did
n't work that way but
that could have worked
also Joey Joey Pizza  uh great
pizza delivery
concept instead of
going abroad somehow they
took the money from Dominos and
sold it
uh so for you it's interation of course
I don't want to rate it at all no
that may be totally legitimate but
it is  you just notice that that's the case
and but it's already clear to you, so
abroad is trying even further, so
you've now got the first F, I've just
sheared it, but you also want to
continue to try it really
seriously,
yes, it's through this
described
It's not an easy expansion in
Germany due to the
scarcity of certain
locations, which is an obvious obvious way to go
and you've
now felt that Italy or
England or France are waiting for you
or are waiting for you there
Italy
isn't yes  By the way, the first
standard in the USA you would also
assume that they were
n't waiting for us but in
Houston W aha aha um we're
even opening the second one today or tomorrow
with the first drivethrough from
koffeeflus okay wow yes yes it's
quite  Exciting because the first store
in the not so great location
actually works quite well for that,
um yes, often you're not
expected to wait, but you can still
do it, I mean, if you're how to get to
Houston, if you can do that then USA,
that would be it  Really then there will be a
super competent, financially strong
franchise partner who simply
contacted us as an American and said he
was in touch with us and
then he said I want to
try this here, I believe
in it but he is really an American
top top man studied Harvard  I was
on Wall Street for a long time and
now I want to
open a lot of stores in a very short time with you and
with us, how did you do it? We
wanted to
sell our location on Mallorca, we
have a location on Mallorca and there
is  He got in touch and then
we couldn't do the transaction
because the existing franchisee did
n't want to sell to Don and
then he said I'm actually from
Houston and I'm
actually only a big Mallorca
fan when I'm on vacation and then
he did  said yes Mart marial huson
I live there and there there is only
Starbucks and Dutch Brothers are the ones
with the energy drinks mhm and I have
the valuation of Dutch Brothers
somehow 400 400 locations 6 billion
dollars on the stock market and let's do that
too
[laughter]
make
everything a little shorter and it
wasn't always easy and
but now he's starting there and we've
also got a bit involved in a joint venture,
he also wanted to be involved in the company and now
we're starting and we'll see how far
The trip
is really cool for us, so if the
real S 400 in the USA then
the game is different, yes, and then you
also have, um, then you have a different
rating, so you don't have to be as
small-minded as the two of us
That's exactly what it is, but you
also have to say
that we're still in the
pilot store stage and should
n't there be so much hope
attached to it, of course everything can fail
Gastronomy is a topic that I
follow a bit on the sidelines, that there
is a huge discussion where many
restaurateurs say that it shouldn't be
turned back again, that it was
reduced, I think, in the wake of the pandemic
and now the question is that it will be
lifted again as some see  Since your
excellence is threatened, exactly yes, we are affected by
this sales mix, we only have 25%
food and about
half of that is to go, which is exempt from VAT anyway
or reduced more, we are
not quite as affected as a
restaurant or Wirtzaus or something like that is now
In-house, the people who are most affected
are those who have a lot of food in-house, i.e.
a pizzeria or pub or something like that. We
're not quite as affected, but it
still wouldn't be good. It would
n't be good for the whole industry either. I
actually almost see it that way  From
an industry perspective, because the industry is already
pretty badly hit by Corona,
I'm not saying this in order to
somehow use it politically, it's really the case
that we all
lost money in the Corona situation.
For me it was about 10 million  we
left Corona with more debt
than we went in with, okay mix of
losses and less and less profit
that we would have otherwise made and
additional loans that we had to take out
and so that's what these are
in the balance sheet 19 to 22, you now have
10 million more  Debt that's
for us with a
balance sheet total of somehow 35 40
million that's really a lot yes a
lot Exem extreme you could toe
locations immediately somehow yes that's
really a lot, we'll have to nibble on it for a few years
and we can't
make too big leaps now  and and we're
in such a mode that was
still CAPEX, we have to
be really careful, um fortunately at the
end of next year we'll be
sweating it all out but it's for the whole
industry and now back to
this 7th  % 19% it would
be really good for the industry, it would
really make the industry more attractive in the long term
and make it structurally healthier,
similar to what was achieved with hotels,
um but as a self-confessed
ordoliberal, I can
also understand that it's somehow
difficult  one industry is aimed at supporting the J and
the other is not, but the
bottom line is that out
of I think 27 European countries,
23 have a reduced gastronomy tax,
which also makes sense in a cross-comparison
to support the gastronomy
because they say that somehow it is
still there  more function behind it from a
social perspective than just
making a profit exactly exactly exactly has
a
bit of a certain
function for the cultural
identity of a country also
people come yes okay okay there are other other
plans that I haven't been
able to see in advance somehow so that
I somehow had the Houston thing, yes,
that's also trying to
do it, it's not that crazy because, as I said, it's just a pilot,
but it's super exciting, no other really
big topics, so I mean, there's
a lot on the list of
hotels, maybe then again
Somehow trade is generally a
licensing business is a topic you just said
W would like to solve the trade license
so you can there are other
areas for which you
could issue licenses for a fee
no I think
these LEH products they would
already be in the first step  times
the most block house e.g. makes the gr
super super successful I also have my
own production no yes also much more
credible what your product with which
you then sell on the yes everything to
do with coffee you would have to do for that
we don't have our own Rö 3
I think  If we had our own Rö 3,
which we don't have for
various reasons,
it would probably be a bit more
credible, a bit easier, but
of course you could give a roasting company
license and you don't have a roasting company
because that's too
much investment. We have a roasting company
Investment for reasons is
also a completely different kind of know-how that
we don't have on board at the moment.
We would then have to buy it in
with the risk of failure.
Of course you
also have a bit of a
production. I don't think that's quite the case
I'm also afraid of technology
and of big machines and I do
n't want to have to use a large, tried-and-tested
drum maker. I
just have a bit of respect
for you. Do you actually have the whole donut
trend and so I followed it here
zi years ago  The founder of
Royal Donuts is here again as a guest, um so that's
also a topic that
has somehow completely gone through the roof. I
think it should have leveled off a bit
in the last few
months, so I haven't really noticed it anymore
That's how you see trends like that
and you just have to be very
careful if you invest in it.
At the moment it's cinamoon, so
exactly it was Royal Donut. I do
n't know how it works, but it was
At some point G's was no bubble
tea, so we know what happened to it.
Dunkin also had a line for a
while. Dunkin Donuts in Germany had a
200 m queue in front of every
new opening for a while and
just these sweet these teen sweet
concepts that are over
can be extremely hyped in advance via social media, like
before the opening and so
on, but also have a certain
fall height then,
and at least they always have
the risk that even if it then
goes back to a normal level, that
one always compares it with that
old good times when you had to wait 200 m in line
and if you then go
against the bakeries and
coffee shops and other people with
donuts then that can
be difficult at some point and there
is a certain
trend that that  that,
um, that it only has a certain lifespan,
some of these concepts
and that's dangerous once you
sit on it, that you then feel
too strong as a donut, also a
salesman, super sharp, super sharp, the
concept, no, I mean, if you say yes now,
I'll take it  now bring a few dons in with
you and then one day they'll be out
that they'll take away the whole brand
W my concern, yes,
I think we're in such a settled
environment and people know us and have
coffee and have donuts at your place too  We
can roll out that you could have
included the donuts, but
we don't have the credibility for that, we
would never, so they are always
product specialists who share this fate -
those who only
make bubbleetea or those who only
sell donuts and then they sell
big ones like that  Eights and tens boxes and
one after the other buys them and they
make unbelievable sales per
day but of course that's exactly what they have because they
're so pointed and they also have
a certain height and I find
that totally fascinating and I
really want to begrudge them that too  I can't say I
'm a bit jealous sometimes,
but it's really great that
something like that works, but I've
already seen it two three times
that it went like that for a few
months and then it became
a little less,
well  So let's see what's
happening next
in Hamburg, we're also keeping an eye on it,
but here it's primarily
not coffee fellellow but Campus
Suet, I know two in the area,
why don't you know two brands?
can somehow choose a brand because Campus
has a different product range concept, namely
more hot food, i.e. hearty food,
and we are of the opinion that
Campus fits into certain locations such as
a hospital much better than
a coffee shop because the
hospital employees there have something warm to eat for lunch
need and at KOF you get
a warm iron or something like that but at
Campus Kristal you also get pasta dishes and
soups and various salads and so
on. That's why we stuck to this two
brand strategy and believe
that it was simply more diverse and able to cover a
wider range of locations
in general. I had that
I don't think I've even asked it at the moment, it's
the way you
can do it, it's the way it is in your business. I
think it's clear to me. I want to be
sure to ask the question. Fairy tales are always around.
5% are good, no, if you
can do it in the area, 5%.
Returns, so we say if we
have a location we actually want to have 15%
to 20% EBIT there, that means you
still have a certain amount of time to
pay back your leasing payments, but
5% is almost a bit low, okay,
so I would say that  so
pre-tax pre-tax I would say something like
this EBIT is more like 10% okay okay and and
and an EBIT there at 15 to 18
okay then the business that is
currently operating in total is probably
still quite yes then don't do
Corona, yes can  you can
say yes, so we want we want
somewhere around the close we
can't quite manage 10% of external sales as EBIT
so 12 yes so we're at
10 9 10 11 next so in this in this
range but still  Congratulations,
my very much bootrap, so to speak,
prevailed against everyone else, yes, yes,
no, thank you very much, it wasn't always
not always easy, but of course also
with this long time, we
also have a super loyal
team for a long time that has been there for so long and
simply too  After a while you also have
a certain amount of experience in the
industry, so
we've all become coffee shop specialist nerds
and when you get to the location you know that
somehow much better
than at the beginning but after 32 pieces
we're already  In any case,
also humble because it's not always easy and it's
not an easy industry, so
it's easier to earn 10 million EUR
than with 260
locations, franchises and everything else,
a lot depends on the purchase of raw materials
at the end of the world from our point of view
yes if I if I then
sometimes
other people who studied with me at the time,
not all of them
but there are also others
who earn their money much more easily
with consulting
or
yes entrepreneurs or private equity or
invested in some way or yes well but
because you have  yes value created me in the
end the great value l in the company no
so if they can now permanently make 10 20
million days then it will be
difficult for a consultant
to get to your value because you yes
that is of course the case but yes yes of course no
We are too, we are also totally
grateful, it
's all great, but the corona time
was extremely difficult and we are
currently doing it and
swimming freeus again as I already
said and these are all values
without Corona and after  everything is paid back
and then 25 you can then
somehow invest in cash again
and you don't have to
pay it back so great respect for me,
a history of money for so many
years plus a gold medal and
what more could you want so it's already
really big and yes I am  I'm curious,
maybe one day the
news will come that you're handing it over to the next
generation or
going public in the USA, I don't know, in any
case, thank you very much, thank you very much,
all right, ciao
ciao